I get to lead a team of fantastic and
Brilliant concept artists and our role
is to create the characters that you see
in the game that's everything from the
main hero cast you see to the creatures
the Gods and Monsters that you come
across the hope is that we get something
that feels unique and stands up to the
history and the legacy of what the God
of War franchise has always done I feel
like from the first games that was a
similar approach that they were doing
and that's not always easy
foreign
I'm the art director for God of War
Ragnarok my name is Marissa coppert I'm
a character technical artist hi my name
is Angela Rico and I am a senior
character artist in God of War Ragnarok
hi I'm Della longfish and I am the lead
of the character concept team at Santa
Monica Studio come in
what in all Yarns be the happen to him
as a character technical artist here at
SMS I rig most of the characters and
props that you see throughout the world
as character artists audio is to create
3D assets based on the beautiful concept
that are provided to us we do this by
making sure that the Silhouettes on the
models and the textures and materials
stand out instantaneously so when you
see our characters on the screen we want
you to almost like them immediately or
have a connection to them to some extent
before even interacting with them as our
director I get the chance to collaborate
with all the departments in the studio
from from narrative to this Dev because
we want to make sure the factions feel
correct all the races belong to where
they they're supposed to be like all the
Realms I have very specific
characteristics about them to make sure
that all fits within the God of War
Universe sorry one more thing although
these are gifts I'm giving to you so I
shouldn't be sorry and you should be
thankful anyways here please be careful
in the God of War 2018 we saw Brock and
cindering that was the tip of the
iceberg of the whole drug and in God of
War Ragnarok we actually get to go and
visit spiral hunt where they're from and
a great part of that too we want to make
sure that we expand the cast you know
we've just seen a little bit of what was
represented and that was something that
we hadn't seen swaddleheim is a
beautiful place there's a lot of
different biomes you go from Wetlands to
mountain springs and took a lot of
inspiration from Hot Springs from the
minerals that you find a lot of colorful
minerals a lot of resources so the
dwarfs being the races that they are we
never wanted to play on that as well and
so you see their influence on sorrowheim
on every corner it's around you're going
to find a lot of other environments
there's queries it's a very industrial
city it's very organized and you can see
all the dwarves putting all the work
into creating this great City where they
live in knowing that they're blacksmiths
that that was kind of reflected within
their clothing and you see that within
the houses and every inch we want to
make sure that both the environments and
characters had a cohesiveness that felt
like every inch of it felt like it went
together and was designed specifically
by event and again that's something that
we haven't seen in some of the other
Realms and is unique to this characters
and their location and to hope it all
goes together and creates a feeling
within around that you're excited to see
feels unique and really creates that
sense of wonder where you want to go
back
when designing a character to match the
geography around it uh first it's
definitely dictated by the vist dev team
and the narrative team in the story team
they make sure the character has
designed for features that fit in with
what they need when designing the Grims
we took a lot of inspiration from the
environment so we took a lot of
inspiration from lizards creatures that
kind of belong to that environment they
have those big claws there's small
Critters to the big ones and really
building up that race making sure they
kind of belong and that that realm Phil
lived in and that ecosystem felt like
very diverse making sure that it feels
natural and believable is a big part
that goes into Design Elements so our
artist Stephen Oakley put a lot from the
environment Concepts that Luke Berliner
and his team were doing and pulled a lot
of those into actually the skin texture
even the bulk and volumes that you see
in the characters so it really does feel
like not only do they belong in there
but you're able to see them and they
stand out for the combat experiences
with the character
character design is all about
storytelling in the example of darling
his design was really tailored to convey
his own personality he is a bookkeeper
from swarlheim and because his job
demands he's very organized he's very
rigid and he's a very played by the
rules kind of guy but then in contrast
you have his friend so when you see
darling connect with his pet we see that
he's not all just this rigid librarian
guy but that he's got a softer side to
him I do believe that we're all
storytellers no matter what we do even
in the tech side of things I mean we
work to make these characters and then
tell a story and we can also kind of put
those features and traits on our rigs
the prophecies say femble winter leads
to Ragnarok war is coming
swarheim the dwarves working with
different races from different Realms so
definitely seeing Ragnarok at the impact
of that into the realm it puts them into
this position that's very interesting to
see which side they take and things that
they're building so as you go through
the level you find out a lot more about
this race and the political situation
that is happening while Ragnarok and
fimbal winter is taking place
oh
they're uh running away one thing that
our hope is with the cast of characters
within every realm is not that it's just
enemies there to kill you we want to
feel believable and that there's a wide
world out there but we want to kind of
plant these seeds within any cast of The
Realm that there's more outside of what
you're playing we want the fans to feel
like they can go back and really visit
those areas and want to go explore if
the geysers and smell here are worse
because of fumble winter
maybe the earthquakes are too high going
into this for him I'm really excited for
players to experience all the new races
that lived in that realm how they play
they play very different from anything
we had before there's a wildlife it's
something that kind of goes unnoticed
but we took a lot of effort to make the
realm feel believable so there's a lot
in farhheim a lot to explore I'm really
excited for starlaheim it is a gorgeous
realm after looking through some of the
cinematics and playing some of the
cinematics and playing through some of
the puzzles I'm so excited how water
plays such a big feature in that realm
and that is so cool I'm most excited for
fans to finally get to see how the
dwarves live broadcast India were fun
favorites in the last game so I think
that all the work that we've put into
spiralheim is going to make all the
other door shine just as bright as the
brothers did the best part I have is
turning onto YouTube and seeing all
these callouts and all the attention the
detail that the fans pick up on that's
one thing that we keep in mind when
we're designing characters to make sure
we do right by the fans and knowing that
all the work we put in will be seen and
appreciated that's not always the case
but our plans just get every little
looking cranny on that and we love that
and we packed a lot of that in for this
new cast and we hope you guys get the
same feeling with God of War Ragnarok
[Music]